Introducing Seeing AI.
Seeing AI is an intelligent camera.
It can provide you with information about
you and what is around you.
That’s perfectly useful for someone with
a vision impairment.
Just hold up your phone and hear a description.
Like when asking a friend, there will be different
things you want to know about.
So switch between the channels, like you would
on a TV.
And you’ll hear different types of information
being spoken out.
You can read short pieces of text or scan
an entire document.
You can recognize products, people and other
objects like currency.
Let’s take a look at each channel in detail.
Microsoft logo appears.